[Musica]
non potete aspettarvi da me qualità di
videogioco questo lo sappiamo dal
momento in cui ho aperto il canale bella
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovissimo video io sono qua vj e oggi
siamo su penso che si possa descrivere
da solo leggo quello che c'è scritto nel
menu dottor fast ass
il gioco dell'anno 2010 ragazzi vi
faccio il riassunto di quello che ho
sentito praticamente lui è un dottore
che ha dato vita con questa macchina a
uno spaghetto sostanzialmente basta
quindi posso muovermi da sinistra a
destra lotta cioè posso muovere lo
spaghetto non ho capito niente
qual è la direzione che dovrei prendere
spiega sono uno spaghetto eccolo il
traguardo sono fortissimo 3 di spaghetti
signori 3 euro su steve allora è bella è
bellissimo perché è un indice anche con
la cia la trama c'è anche doppiato
bellissimo va bene bravo freddi andiamo
a secondo livello è venuto pulsante già
per saltare più in alto è la madonna
quel pulsante di jump che ne so io a
quella cosa non ho capito qual è il
pulsante jump ma da che parte si guarda
questo pensavo fosse da quando pensavo
di dover saltare da qua qua invece è un
comodino ara il tasto destro e il giallo
del tasto sinistro del verde mi devo
ricordare questa pronuncia però mai
acosta minchia sto giocando jolo è
difficilissimo però certo è come cacchio
faccio veramente veramente difficili so
no maloba cock and physical risalire
non posso non si può fare è capiscimi
non devo arrivare fino alla fine perché
se non salta quindi ho scoperto sta roba
best gamer 2021 stare qua sono cascata
pavimentato sono pavimentato scusate non
ho capito niente di quello che è
successo perché non devo andare sul tipo
come high end prendere casey uguale no
ma poi il demonio ragazzi c'è anche del
dramma in questo gioco è capace di tutto
per 3 euro seconda di cosa a microonde
let's colour dio benedetto quando lo
stare attento e non beccare i fornelli
accesi scommetti buono beccare
bravissimo sicuro che hanno dove creare
attenzione attenzione proprio lui
mammamia spaghetto number one ragazzi
incredibile livello 7 basta basta mai
fino a quel giorno fatidico ad ora per
lo schiacciamento una tastiera ma sei
scemo ma come co
ma è impossibile no ragazzi io mi viene
più portato in italiano e la posizione
dei tasti è proprio quella della
tastiera quello sto scrivendo veramente
perché i tassi sono quelli cosa sono gli
spaghetti
io veramente non so cosa ma kimi che ha
inventato sto già un genio ma cosa ma
cosa sto vedendo guarda quanto sono
felice ma non è vero mi stanno
cannibalizzando in una sorta di giovane
no no e freddi la gente non lo fa per
cattiveria lo fa per nutrimento anche
gli spaghetti possono nutrirsi di
non è vero non si nutrono di spaghetti
freddi e calcolatori alla fine del mondo
c'è una puntata di mezzi di love pets
robots non mi ricordo per e dove c'era
lo yogurt che voleva conquistare il
mondo non so se era di love the ten
robles prova per protocollo atu attua
attuato a tua attuale
adesso di vento gigantesco raga aromi
successo già in tanto più grosso sbaglio
pronto
vai schiacciano
[Musica]
voglio neanche non voglio neanche sapere
che fammi vedere nella mia carriera da
youtube ero giocato talmente tanta roba
che non saprei neanche più spiegarvi che
cosa cazzo sto giocando prove comunque
una trama migliori twilight ok tu sei
volte usain bolt lo spaghetto
incredibile no ho trovato la tattica
raga vado velocissimo così non avrei
fatto caso era e non sono uno spaghetto
provetto purtroppo non ho passato gli
anni nella palestra degli spaghetti però
guarda la guarda la come coro guarda la
incredibile
proprio lui no sta arrivando il tour de
france dello spaghetto no è stata
trovato lo presti che è successo chi è
che ha lottato ci ho messo un'ora ma è
stato no a rifredi picchia che suspense
vai frego che la madonna quanta gente
che arrivava i freddi corri madonna che
difficile ce lo porta subito a
stravolgere di vicinissimo ragazzi un
casino ve lo dico veramente un casino
le dita dei piedi quali piedi che non si
ai piedi ice non so come mi sto muovendo
ma mi sto muovendo vai perfetto
by fred bravo madonna ma farò per un
fenomeno un fenomeno guarda lì non mi
impegnano più
minchia come sono stato bravo stavolta
il fenomeno gli o tripla di tutti
no non è vero non certo non l'ha detto
che ha detto che è sopravvissuto a
malapena questo tempo ve lo assicuro io
che la traduzione non rendeva giustizia
arrivando alla fine del ponte porco
demonio ci ho messo sei anni se madonna
ora non si muove neanche più
assolutamente stanco che non si muoveva
augurio non avete i tele la difficoltà
di fare questa cosa che sembra una
cagata farla razzistici poi o le cagate
alle soggiogare a chi sta parlando lui
chi sta parlando il creatore il dottor
pasta freddi lei la madonna una lacrima
strappa storia una storia strappalacrime
una lacrima storia strappa ok è tutto
così romantico ragazzi quali strappi
lacrima storie sono non si finiscono in
un video mi sento un veramente in colpa
aver mangiato un sacco di spaghetti
nella mia vita per adesso concludiamo
qua ma sono sicuro che non storico
freddi saprà cavarsela magari in un
prossimo episodio che dite che siamo
ragazzi svegli sia piaciuto chiedeva che
ha lasciato un commento quando tutto
cosa ne pensate per adesso era come
sempre ci vediamo ad un prossimo video
della ragazza
[Musica]